DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello,
I'm Dustin Kirkland,
Product Manager at Google.
And I'm joined here by
my colleague Sebastien
Goasguen at Bitnami,
where he leads Kubernetes.
Sebastien, can you
tell me a little bit
about what you're hearing
from users and customers
about Kubernetes in
Bitnami's sphere?
SEBASTIEN GOASGUEN: Sure.
At Bitnami, as you said, I lead
all the community's efforts
open source.
So we work on
application packaging
specifically for Kubernetes,
so of course, containers.
But then we package, and
we deliver on Kubernetes.
GKE, of course, is one
of the target platforms.
And it's still a little
bit early, you know.
I mean, the conference
is booming--
4,000 people.
But it's still
early in the space,
where users are migrating
to Microservices
and Cloud-native applications.
So they need a lot
of help in first,
understanding the
entire space, and then
understanding how
their application is
going to look like in
Kubernetes on that platform.
So we help them
do that, and then
we help them package those apps,
make the good choices in terms
of containerizing them, using
things like Helm charts,
or maybe GitHub's
pipeline to deploy.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
So you've really seen this shift
in development methodologies
from the developer's
perspective.
SEBASTIEN GOASGUEN:
Yeah, and personally, I
like to think of
it also as-- it's
more of a general
shift with DevOps
and being able to be
extremely quick to market,
to react extremely
quickly, compared
to a more traditional type
of application development,
where that's slower and
people need months or years
to deploy apps.
Here, we see people
realizing that they
need to go extremely quickly.
So that's where Microservices,
containers, and then a platform
like Kube makes it extremely
easy, with rolling updates.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
CI/CD, of course.
SEBASTIEN GOASGUEN: CI/CD, of
course, which is integrated.
But interestingly, we
have to be realistic.
A lot of people are
still not there.
So yes, CI/CD.
But we need to help those people
who are maybe not quite there
yet with their pipeline, with
their software development
pipeline, get them on board with
this new wave of doing apps.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
And where do you see the
challenges are right now?
Where are people
stubbing their toes?
SEBASTIEN GOASGUEN:
Well, so you need
to help them understand the
impact of those technologies.
I always say, adopting a
tech just because that's
the new thing, going Kubernetes
just because Kubernetes
is really hot right now--
that's not a good reason.
So they really need to
understand that they
need a software factory.
They need developers on
board with using a version
control, of course, but
then automatically building
containers, understanding
the manifests for Kubernetes.
So it's an entire
lifecycle of software,
lifecycle of the application,
that they need to embrace.
And we need to start
at the beginning, which
is the dev, of course.
And then we need to
approach the operators,
because it's a big
change for the operators
of the infrastructure.
They need to be on board with
adopting the Kubernetes API
to manage this infrastructure.
So it's an entire effort
there of transformation
for [INAUDIBLE].
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
So you're quite involved
in the community.
And you've certainly
seen and met
a lot of people around
Kubernetes over the years.
Who are some of the people
that inspire you, maybe you
want to give a
shout out to or give
a thanks to on camera here?
SEBASTIEN GOASGUEN: I
started in Kubernetes 2014,
when I wrote the
"Docker Cookbook."
So I met Joe Bida
remotely, and he
helped me write some of
the Kubernetes content
before he went GA.
So I can't say that
I was there early.
But I don't work on core.
I really work on the edge,
because I created a startup
which was acquired by Bitnami.
So I'm really on the edge, not
really contributing to core
per se.
But the people I
really admire, Joe Bida
is one of them--
extremely smart,
of course-- which was at Google
before and worked on GCE.
And then I have to say
that Brian Grant is
quite impressive to
me as a smooth guy,
quiet but extremely sharp.
And when you point out
a technical problem,
he brings up a GitHub issue
or a PR with its number,
so it's quite impressive.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Well,
thank you, Sebastien.
Appreciate your time.
Yeah, cheers.